so there was celebration yesterday
confetti was thrown
champagne was poured tears of joy were
wept
when the actress ellen page revealed
that she is a man
named elliot yes apparently it seems
ellen page who has been a woman for 33
years of life
is actually a man she says and for this
urgent news bulletin
as always we'll go to people magazine
here's their report
elliot page is living his truth and
coming out as transgender
page formerly known as ellen released a
heartfelt statement on twitter tuesday
writing in part quote
i want to share with you that i am trans
my pronouns are he
they and my name is elliot paige added i
feel lucky to be writing this
to be here to have arrived at this place
in my life the 33 year old known for his
oscar-nominated role in the film juno
goes on to express overwhelming
gratitude for those who have supported
his journey adding quote
i can't begin to express how remarkable
it feels to finally love who i am enough
to pursue my authentic self
paige also asks fans for patience in the
statement explaining that his joy is
fragile and that he is scared of
invasiveness
hate jokes and violence he also
addresses the discrimination against the
trans community
calling it insidious and cruel resulting
in horrific consequences
according to page's post in 2020 alone
it has been reported that at least 40
transgender people have been murdered
he adds that the majority of those
victims have been black and latinx trans
women
page also calls out political leaders
who continue to criminalize trans health
care
and deny individuals their right to
exist he states that those who spew
hostility towards the trans community
have blood on their hands because 40
percent of trans adults report
attempting suicide
page goes on to directly address trans
people who deal with a quote
threat of violence every day saying he
sees and loves them
and promises that he will do everything
he can to change this world for the
better
last year paige revealed that he married
dancer emma portner who reposted this
statement on her instagram tuesday
writing in the caption that she is proud
of paige and calling his existence a
gift
in and of itself okay everything you
heard at the end there was
completely false actually it was all
completely false especially the part
where she said her authentic self is a
man but
the claim that trans people are the
victim of a hate crime epidemic has
simply no evidence to support it there
is a similar lack of evidence to support
the claim
that health care for trans people is
being criminalized
and that trans people are being denied
the right to exist
there's only one group of people in this
country who are denied the right to
exist and they're still in the womb
the pro-abortion page doesn't care about
that group though of course
she'd rather fight imaginary injustices
than real ones
speaking of imaginary especially
imaginary injustices you may recall a
couple years ago ellen page
on tv with uh stephen colbert blaming
mike pence
for the hate crime that jesse smallett
committed against himself
it's worth revisiting that rant i think
because it raises an interesting
question listen
i'm like really fired up tonight this is
how this is how you have to be fired it
feels impossible to not feel this way
right now
with the president and the vice
president mike pence who like wishes i
couldn't be married let's just be clear
the vice president of america wishes i
didn't have the love
with my wife he wanted to ban that in
indiana
he believes in conversion therapy
he has hurt lgbtq people so badly as the
government of indiana and i think the
thing we need to know and i hope my show
gaycation did this
in terms of connecting the dots in terms
of what happened the other day did you
say i don't know him personally i sell
i send all of my love
connect the dots this is what happens
if you are in a position of power and
you hate people
and you want to cause suffering to them
you go through the trouble you spend
your career
trying to cause suffering what do you
think is gonna happen
kids are gonna be abused and they're
gonna kill themselves
and people are gonna be beaten on the
street
i have traveled the world and i have met
the most marginalized people you can
meet
i am lucky to have this time and the
privilege to say this
this needs to stop okay leaving aside
the rather
stupefying fact that ellen page was
somehow trying to blame the vice
president for the fact that two
imaginary men beat up an actor in
chicago while he was walking to subway
at 2 a.m and sub-zero temperatures
we we do have to ask one question ellen
page was
referring to her own same-sex lesbian
marriage to another woman
now with this revelation that she's a
man named elliot
does that mean she was never really a
lesbian was she a straight white male
this whole time
and if so does that mean a straight
white male was playing all those roles
in all those films that
should have gone to real women does she
have to give back all of the awards
she's received for best female lead in
the film
well maybe all of the awards overstates
a little bit but she has won a couple of
awards i think at least
do those get returned or did she just
become a man now if so how did that
happen
and if she did just become a man doesn't
that mean she actually changed her
sexual orientation going from gay to
straight
isn't that impossible haven't we been
told that's impossible
by the way mere nanoseconds after page
made the announcement her wikipedia
pages and imdb
imdb pages had been changed immediately
to
include the new pronouns lightning speed
this change was made
creepy enough but to make things weirder
page's wikipedia
page now if you go and check it out
identifies her as a gay man
married to a woman does that make sense
how does it make sense these are these
are just a few of the questions that
those who promote left-wing gender
theory
the theory that makes it possible
allegedly for ellen page to become a man
or be a man or to have always been a man
while also being a woman
cannot answer will not answer we're
meant to simply accept
that this woman is a man even though
nobody
who makes the claim including ellen
herself can offer any explanation of it
they cannot tell you when she became a
man
how she became a man how any of this is
possible scientifically or logically
in fact the people making the claim
cannot even so much as explain
what the claim actually is think about
that for a moment
ellen page says she's a man okay
what does she mean by that with all
these people announcing that they're
really a gender other than
the one that they were quote assigned at
birth
the crazy thing is that nobody ever
stops to ask the simplest
most basic question what do you mean
what do you mean that's a fair question
isn't it that's a it's not a transphobic
question or a question that authorizes
anyone or denies anyone the right to
exist
it's also not a question that shuts
anyone down or shouts them down
or censors them quite the opposite this
is a question that seeks to understand
that seeks even to take the claim
seriously
but i cannot understand you or take you
seriously if i don't even know what you
mean
so ellen page says she's a man all right
what do you mean ellen or elliot
what do you mean that you're a man in
what sense are you a man
how do you define the word man what is a
man
i'm a man myself always have been as far
as i know
and it's clear that ellen page is not
exactly like me i mean you could look at
ellen page and look at me and say well
there's a very clear difference here
there there's even a difference of kind
of category it would seem
there are a number of very significant
differences between the two of us
differences that go all the way down to
the level of dna chromosomes
reproductive capabilities bone structure
muscle mass etc
it seems that we're both human certainly
but different kinds of humans
different categories of human now you
say now we're the same kind the same
category well again
then what kind is that explain that kind
define the category and it does no good
to say that the word
man is fluid or an artificial construct
or
that it has no fixed meaning because if
that's the case then it doesn't mean
anything to identify yourself as one
you may as well still call yourself a
woman then because the words don't mean
anything
you can't very well insist that your
identity as this particular thing
is important and fundamental and we all
have to respect it
and also insist that this particular
thing has no meaning and could be
anything
and is nothing but a social construct
you just you do see how those two
propositions are in direct
contradiction don't you see i want to
understand you i do
i just need you to explain what you mean
in a way that's coherent
no it's not that you owe me specifically
an explanation
but if you want to be understood then
you have to explain what you're saying
if you don't want to be understood then
what's the point of making the
announcement in the first place
you know i could stand up in front of
the whole world and say everyone i want
you to know
i am a he what's it that's what i am
that's how i identify if i were to say
that the immediate response from the
world would be
you're a what now what's that what's a
who's what's it what do you mean
i can't very well then respond well i
don't owe you an explanation
stay out of my business i'm the one who
brought it up
the world didn't bring it up i did the
world is just trying to understand what
the hell i'm talking about
but of course when it comes to a woman
saying she's a man or a man saying he's
a woman
no one ever explained explains what's
that supposed to mean
nobody ever explains anything related to
left-wing gender theory a theory that as
we've covered on this show was invented
about 70
years ago by a lunatic child abuser
named john money who experimented on two
young boys and caused them both to kill
themselves
he's the guy who came up with most of
what the left says about gender today
including the idea that a person can
have a gender that is at odds with their
biological sex
he came up with it this is his idea we
are meant now to simply accept and
believe
and parrot these ideas even if they make
no sense
and even if the people making the claim
cannot themselves make sense of it
does it matter though that's the other
question
should we care you know many on the
right realize that left-wing gender
theory is nonsense they realize that men
are not women and women are not men they
realize that this preferred pronoun
stuff is absurd
you know they realize that you cannot
claim your own pronouns for yourself any
more than you can claim your own nouns
or prepositions
or your own adverbs doesn't make any
sense grammar doesn't work that way
language doesn't work that way
they realize all of this but they
retreat from the battle over these ideas
crawling under their beds to hide
while murmuring something about how this
is all a sideshow and it doesn't matter
that is the rationalization of a coward
yes it matters
the truth matters the truth in fact
is all that matters it's the only thing
that matters
i don't care about anything else but the
truth
and i don't care to spend my time
defending anything else but the truth
the last gender ideology is among many
other things
all of them bad a direct assault on the
truth
they want to deny basic truth to build a
culture that denies it
to force you to deny it and that matters
it matters a lot it's also an assault on
children
our children your children gender
confusion is an epidemic
among kids today many lives are being
destroyed by we talked about this last
last week as well we've talked about
this many times because it matters
other conservatives and many other
conservatives with platforms pretend it
doesn't matter but it does
the left wants to infuse confusion into
your child's mind they want to rob
your child of his understanding of
himself
they're trying to take from him what is
most basic most essential
most needed for a happy and healthy life
does that matter
i can think of very few things that
matter more
so yes we do need to say
it is important to say that ellen page
can change her name fine she's elliot
now that's fair you can you can be
whatever name you want to be
but she cannot be a man she's not a man
she will never be one and i say that not
because i'm trying to hurt her feelings
or deny her right to exist
but just because it's true and the truth
matters
well hope you enjoyed that clip from the
matt wall show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content